revista de prensa en directo americana
france24 ya está en el estudio conmigo
rosa pérez más de euros ahí abrimos esta
sección de revista de prensa con una
información de la inteligencia británica
que ha llenado los titulares
internacionales nos fijamos entonces en
el medio de guardián y el de siete en
bonn hicieron buenos días raúl exacto
una información que se complementa con
lo que decías no informaciones también
avanzadas por la inteligencia
estadounidense pero concretamente the
gardian se fija en esta información
británica con el siguiente titular los
consejeros de putting tienen miedo de
decirle la verdad sobre el error de
ucrania según el jefe de la gc hq que es
una agencia de inteligencia británica
bien el jefe de esta agencia jeremy
fleming avanzó estas informaciones en un
discurso en canberra en australia y
cuando se refiere al error en ucrania se
refiere a un error estratégico que ya se
ha comentado también por activa y por
pasiva a lo largo de este mes largo de
invasión que consiste en que putin
habría subestimado la resistencia
ucraniana
pues está occidental y también habría
pues ha sobrevalorado la facilidad pues
de una rápida victoria rusa bien este
artículo de the gardian and sweet up al
jefe de esta agencia británica de
inteligencia que dice que se ha
convertido esto en una guerra personal
de putin que están pagando el precio
pues de esta digamos pues de ese
atrevimiento los ucranianos inocentes y
los rusos de a pie en el marco pues de
la economía rusa y dice que la realidad
sin embargo de este fracaso a pesar de
que putin esté aislado debe ser clara no
para el kremlin que han debido pues ya
darse cuenta de que les está costando
más de lo previsto pues ganar esta
guerra en ucrania algo en lo que
coincide como decíamos la inteligencia
de eeuu que dice que como consecuencia
de este aislamiento insiste putin
estaría dando órdenes a ciegas a su
ejército y particularmente en esto se
fija este medio australiano el sydney
morning herald que dice que el ejército
ruso estaría pues bajo de moral y escaso
de armamento y cita una información que
avanzó el jefe de esta agencia británica
en este discurso en la capital
australiana y es que hay soldados que se
niegan a cumplir las órdenes del kremlin
que sabotean su equipamiento e incluso
derribaron un avión ruso da constancia
de que fleming sin embargo no aportó
pruebas de éste derribamiento de un
avión ruso por parte por parte de las
propias tropas rusas pero que sin
embargo consultaron con el ministerio de
defensa de londres que aseguró que
estaban suficientemente
convencidos de esta información como
para permitir que este jefe del
espionaje británico pues la dijera
abiertamente
pues en público no en este discurso pero
raúl cabe destacar que esto no deja de
ser la estrategia que ha venido usando
occidente desde el inicio de esta guerra
no dar públicamente las informaciones
que se tienen que se obtienen a través
de la inteligencia occidental para
digamos demostrar evidenciar pues los
defectos no del enemigo pero ya ha
salido el portavoz de la presidencia
peskov de la presidencia rusa a decir
que estas informaciones son falsas que
es falso que putin esté mal informado y
raúl aquí pues llegamos a la conclusión
de que si tan aislado estuviera putin
pues no serviría de nada que se hicieran
públicas estas informaciones no no le
harían daño al kremlin rosa vamos rápido
porque el tiempo es corto y tenemos
mucho que hablar a pesar de todo la
popularidad del presidente putin no baja
sino todo lo contrario no de eso
exactamente nos informa el wall street
journal con la información de evans
gershkovitch y es que en el último mes
la popularidad del presidente ruso
habría pasado del 71% al 83 por ciento
esto según la organización levada center
que en teoría es una organización
independiente de hecho considerada como
agente extranjero por el kremlin ahora
sí hay que poner entre comillas está
supuesta independencia más todavía en el
contexto actual nos recuerda este
artículo que este índice de popularidad
del 83% putin no lo alcanzaba desde la
anexión de crimea en 2014 y por otro
lado en este texto también nos dice que
también ha incrementado la gente que
piensa que el país va en la buena
dirección que en enero era de un 50 por
ciento en febrero de un 52% y ahora el
69% de los rusos consideran pues que
rusia digamos va en buen camino ahorros
y está vamos ahora entonces con un tema
relacionado con esta guerra el salto se
fija particularmente en la situación de
los refugiados ucranianos trans hoy
justamente en el día de la visibilidad
trans efectivamente esta es una historia
contada por anna rojas que se fijan
particularmente en mi familia es esta
mujer que vemos aquí en la imagen que ya
se encuentra en alemania tras haber
podido huir de ucrania y ella lo que
relata es que las personas lgtb de plus
pues se encuentran bajo una doble guerra
en ucraniano por un lado víctimas de los
ataques a civiles y por otro lado de
discriminación y ataques de odio pues en
un contexto de mucha vulnerabilidad
precisamente ella cuenta que cuando
empezó la guerra recibió una llamada de
una ong pro derechos lgtb que le dijo
que había gente armada persiguiendo pues
a las personas no de sexualidades
disidentes ella dijo yo no tenía miedo a
la guerra tenía miedo a los homófobos y
tránsfobos armados en el país ella fue
criada como un hombre en el seno de una
familia conservadora de crimea eso nos
explica rojas en este artículo y
consiguió escapar cruzando la frontera
de rumanía a nado eso después de que
intentara pasar a través de checkpoints
por corredores humanitarios pero de que
el ejército ucraniano se lo negara
porque en su puesta cédula de identidad
todavía está clasificada bajo el género
masculino ella explica que al ser una
persona conocida porque como comentaba
esto al inicio de este programa es
influencer y artista tenían el ejército
órdenes a directas de que ella entrara
en el ejército
de hecho ella explica cómo incluso el
presidente ucraniano selenski se llegó a
burlar de ella antes de las últimas
elecciones presidenciales en ucrania y
al final no le quedó otro remedio que
escapar como decíamos cruzando a nado a
través después del río que separa
ucrania de y ahí fue acogida pues como
una refugiada rosa gracias por toda la
información pasamos a saludar ahora a
nuestras dos invitadas del día